will they give a reaction to his weather  in the lounge  on this  he's taking a little bit of a break  we'll have a quick chat with pronoun to  see if he can have a chat it was it  seemed to be a clever end game and very  good technique by aneesh here  um no i think when he went for an end  game  i thought instead of king at six he  could just take queen at six and i  i didn't see any way i mean i thought it  was already very bad for me  um but end game i thought i had some  chances but probably it was nothing um  yeah i just want to focus on the next  games and try to make a comeback  hopefully you got the fighting spirits  going  oh yeah good luck to you